deus ex mankind divided has only been  out for a few weeks but if you're ready  for DLC it's coming soon I'm Tony and  this is your augmented gamespot news  update the first story DLC is called  system rift and it'll feature security  chief frank pritchard last seen in human  Revolution Pritchard and Adam Jensen  will team up to take on the palisade  blade one of the most secure data banks  in the world along the way Adam will  learn more about the Illuminati and  you'll get more deus ex action or  stealth or hacking or whatever path you  choose system rift comes to ps4 xbox one  and pc on sep tember 23rd it'll cost you  12 bucks or nothing at all if you own  the season pass mankind divided second  story dlc a criminal past will release  in early 2017 but we don't know much  about that expansion yet to keep up with  all the latest from Deus Ex you're  already in the right place